in no common sense news Oh a lot of
people don't have this submitted by just
John oh it was [ __ ] like the Sistine
Chapel finger it's all we can lift
that's when you're so drunk tit but
somebody made a good point here are some
of the most interesting items
the TSA confiscated in 2017 oh oh I mean
- the TSA this will be pretty morning
I've been stupid and I don't expect
anyone in this room to know but I'm
gonna just put it up I know it what what
are we about to ask okay cool what did
it what does TSA do with the items at
the conference they jack off with it
they sell money man they hold a
nationwide a nationwide TSA auction I'm
googling it and they give to charity
they burn in a bush that's all right my
assumption is that some of them take it
home yeah hell yeah yeah you know it's
the first line of this a common
misconception is that TSA officers take
the items for their own personal ball
you got Rick no one else told the reason
why I thought that was because I was I
was trying to board a plane right and
then at checkpoint TSA pulled out like a
bottle facewash and they're like oh what
is this and I was like its face wash it
was like okay well you can't bring this
on I'm like okay then just take it and
then the lady she takes it she's like
hmm interesting she walks away with it I
was like you're gonna take that home and
then she's like Jimmy is this natural
yeah
asking me questions about it I'll look
it up is this your sensitive skin well
there's the second line here is any TSA
employee caught pocketing items
collected at swimming checkpoints will
determine a be okay the park trashed it
through the ocean or she could have used
it and then put it back on the common
use pile
me you know I don't buy the official
account whatever the [ __ ] I love those
quotations by the way no yeah come on no
I mean okay so so because this article
says they don't do that they don't do
that right we know that's like how they
say oh there's been no civilian deaths
in drone strikes oh yeah
well my brother was there but it's a lot
your brother's dead no he was there he
saw these things happen so it's you know
not so cut and dry don't killing
innocent people drones with Obama era
there's a controversy
oh yeah but then all of a sudden they
stop after a certain year it's like oh
there's now no civilian deaths like all
of a sudden like oh really
that's what the official counts is so I
yeah yeah they play fast and loose with
the facts all right so the TSA Instagram
account apparently is a very funny
account now that I'm looking into it I
need to follow it they use a lot of like
puns with all the things that they find
you know what I'm really proud of TSA
cuz they really clean themselves up
there they're better now customers they
have tagged just wait just wait better
I'm really I used to hate the [ __ ] out
of them
and also I realized a lot of our fans
are TSA to ER so when we walk by delay
hey Joe and all that stuff and I'm like
alright cool man I used to I used to
think you guys are [ __ ] but you're
all right with me hey they don't want to
use half of those machines like the one
that makes you go like this doesn't even
work everyone knows that it doesn't work
because I can't scan the sides of your
body or whatever the hell it is but it
just give you cancer well I don't know
what it is but for some reason we they
have to use them so I think even the TSA
guys the fans they don't even want to do
that [ __ ] they think it sucks too and
every time I pass by I'm always like
thank you for protecting I feel like
they protected they do a lot of good I
had an incident where I forgot that I
left the knife in my carry-on theme and
then I put it on you know I brought it
on they're like oh hey dude is this
yours and I'm like yeah and he's like
well you could go back and then put it
and check in so he was cool with it like
he was like yeah you just can't put it
bring it in your carry-on no mine was
the credit card no a fan gave it to us
I remember Gio handing them to me so I
got it from you and then I left it in my
wallet
I'm just hood I gave knives away they're
really cool about I thought Julia did it
whoo the way she said no and I thought
like after after the shoot like we'd say
okay thanks and then and close the
camera down and then she's like if you
ever tell people I'll give you weapons
again
there's enough no one knows the true
Julia we don't wanna mess with Julie's
great well change the subject guys thank
you thank you loving all these comments
guys thank you so here's one of the
things that they've confiscated would
you like to read the caption yes Jane
hashtag caption this while there was
nothing hidden inside the replica 50
caliber bullet there was a sword
concealed within the cane both swords
and replica bullets are not allowed in
carry-on bags or on your person really
no [ __ ]
right you can take them in okay they may
be packed in checked luggage concealed
sources this one can lead to fines and
arrests this was discovered with the
travelers carry-on items at Chattanooga
that was pretty cool yeah a lot of these
actually a lot of people hide knives and
stuff in there cane that's super illegal
in California I think it's more than
you'll than having a gun oh damn there's
like certain weapons like nunchucks and
my brass nut balls who ever heard anyone
nunchucks you look like an idiot a lot
of white guys have nunchucks exactly
white guys with fedoras would you know
and they have Trent long trench coats
you know a couple swords on the wall oh
man next one the treats are okay just as
long as there's no tricks in them this
Saint CROs STX passenger brought all
that and a bag of chips we don't mean to
ruffle any feathers Oh God they're
trying but knives are not allowed in
carry-on bags or on your person I've
maybe packed and checked luggage
concealed knife such as this one can
lead to fines and a hashtag happy
Halloween so wait this was in a and the
ruffles yeah okay I guess they use a lot
of puns in their Instagram posts are
pretty funny I like this next one Oh
tough Klingon war blade ooh this weapon
will not only help you defend yourself
against orcs cheeky mint but it also
allows you to butter two slices of toast
at the same time this one was discovered
in a carry-on bag at Chicago Midway
please pack items such as this in your
checked bags
I feel like the writer for the TSA his
real dream was to be like a sketch
writer stand up right or some [ __ ] and
then he couldn't make it so now he's
you're finding yourself as he's writing
anything he's like maybe they'll find me
enter you know I hate putting it out
there I know look I'm funny see yeah I
like it a PR team somebody's like well
I'm going to Florida
why can't I bring my lay with me that's
that's the kind of [ __ ] you leave like
in a display case at your house but this
[ __ ] thought of like oh you know
there might be some some guys that are
trying to rob me or something no no no
these guys get that because you're like
oh yeah that's right I'm gonna afford to
get [ __ ]
oh yeah I'll bring I'll bring that they
think chicks are gonna I think they're
tough dude some guys think that kind of
I know they do
it's like guys were like hey have you
seen my wanna yet she's like hey look I
gotta go I think my brother's dying like
as soon as the guy talks about how he
wants you to see his lizard there you
find out he's a lizard guy get the [ __ ]
out of there yeah the girlfriends okay
there's a pretty hot she hot she's
pretty hot can't see a Peggy no they
came by Canyon green he's a lizard but
he got the girlfriend first hedare right
he actually seems like a lizard guy but
yeah he's pretty cool no he had lizards
first spiky lizards Bri came after the
lizards does Bri know about the she
she's a reptile girl herself I'm done
with this video like this reptilian my
affectionate Society
oh that's cool are you [ __ ] going
into prison Yeah right
those brush and comb daggers are hair
brained items that will get you tangled
up in the security line all knives are
not allowed in carry-on bags or on your
person blah blah blah blah blah this is
like the [ __ ] they had in Greece well
part look Kenickie is like you know like
they don't mess with me pal like like
that kind of [ __ ] you know I'm talking
about I think they had this [ __ ] in that
movie you know home holder people back
there that big talk so goofy but they
were actually pretty damn gangster like
whatever we see on screen
it's like the watered-down version of
real-life Frank Sinatra was a gangster
oh yeah he looks like that next one here
hey that's Bart's method yeah yeah what
really did it when I was slinging weed
in high school I said keep it in my
deodorant bar and I thought it was
genius see how my dad found me I was
like what the [ __ ] man your dad should
have been a detective yeah [ __ ] did you
find that [ __ ] notice that's why I put
in the other bars no way you could smell
it yeah he could have saw you too I was
all like yeah like how all of these like
most interesting items are just knives
hidden in friendships but I thought
they'd like you know have some like cool
[ __ ] there's more I wish there was a
dildo with a knife in it that'd be
interesting well they need to be knives
because then you know what's the purpose
of confiscating something like eight
ounce bottle of gel yeah exactly see
something like crazy instagram-worthy
that's not interesting you know I think
it's like it's like a big jug of beer or
something that'd be really interesting
[ __ ] five-gallon jug of olive oil
container lifetime supply Wow that'd be
crazy [ __ ] some burns you can care at
that show this one says this gives
protection a whole new meaning
however fine stink oh wait let them see
the beginning oh yeah okay what about
all the the guns there are some guns in
here I didn't all these guns I thought
they were very interesting this was kind
of interesting too they said some people
worry about packing nail clippers
they're allowed others Peck a pound of
gunpowder infused this was discovered in
a checked bag
a bomb right there gunpowder in a fuse
okay Julia you get caught with that and
your I've got the counter they open your
bag and that's in there
what's your explanation go I asked my
nation I'll be like oh it's just for
like some sort of art project that I'm
working on sort of our project our
project you know and I just I just want
to make what university you go - oh you
know just like one of the ones in
universities in California Oh year oh
wow
okay I didn't know you're that
percentage Humphries carry on I'll be
like I'm making fireworks for Chinese
New Year I'd be like yeah I'll tell you
when I see a [ __ ] warrant oh yeah
where's your warrant pal and they're
like we have a right to do this this is
our job like you have no rights here and
I might I would like to see the
Constitution please I think I have some
constitutional rights in our be and
they're like shut the [ __ ] up again in
the car pal you think the founding
fathers were all criminals so they're
like I think I want to just a looped
video of you saying do you think the
founding fathers were all criminals